hello and welcome to this video playing
shu-kun de la from the US okay um yeah
let's do this I have a really terrible
square minus 2 1 win three losses be
five Wow okay so you really don't want
to CC form okay getting some Kings
Indian attack here that's not bad should
one be seven is some misplaced belongs
to a 6 normally like after a five or
just stay on c8 okay it's not like I'm
winning way you think would usually my
from the bishop is prefer to be not on
b7 so 3 h 5 camp so what do i do go back
from the yASA for the PSAC next I mean
he's got 93 and but ok mate comes first
I'm a hard time
to believe that black f5 he wants to
play some f 5 stuff we take age 60
probably place h f5 on later f5 yeah
anyway I'm going to take care so yes so
now I have to trade do I you know I can
cover c3 now but of course the attack is
over which is a bit of a shame because
it looked very very dangerous it's not
that easy i think i mean i have them
feeling I have this permit it is not
super straightforward win in at least I
don't don't see it like that
you can still play that d 4 + 95 baby
yes III is quite enormously week yeah I
think I have to do this I have to go for
this pin and then thou just take the
five I mean okay totally cannot move
there I still think I'm doing this come
on get rid of this this bloody piece and
now how do I a Knight to c4 would be
good but this is very difficult to
achieve
My dear sir oopsie to move the Bishop
Knight d2 z forward two step by step
improve i also have night age 32 f 1
this this is a good move this is a good
idea d5 yeah IM that should do this
first before I do anything else let's do
this tying some peas to the defense of
his successor must be good okay so he
retreats
95 I'm cake oh yeah the long diagonal oh
my god I kind of forget it forgot about
that I have all those fancy maneuvers
but i'm getting checkmated I mean not
not directly but hey I'm very serious
part of this position the edge farm
not to be for now as an issue men what's
what kind of crap pretty awful really I
just got it to coordinate again and then
I didn't see the H file or the Sun
becoming super important
oh my god cat this is nightmare this
position it's completely without any
coordination
hi rookie 5 at the end to this I said
sth to anyway look H do I take take
everything take a tool this is the
problem that can doesn't matter him I'm
already sick of this game
91 know what may be major time morning
what a joke check I completely gifted
everything in this game amazing check
check
it's still kind of interesting because
of the time check check your blender in
the Rocky Top yeah I mean I'm sorry I'm
afraid as I mean what that's on time I
mean I just have to avoid this g5
[ __ ] I'm just just a pawn up for
nothing yeah I mean crazy it's probably
still good but um yeah maybe I shouldn't
take your five I don't know it's a this
is these decisions are tough that the
engine actually agrees I can flick
Alexis this on basically am yes s is
nothing but I didn't really coordinate
this position well I was kind of I
always wanted to put a Knight to c4
maybe this is just a bad idea anyway it
would be fantastic if I kept a fantastic
i can but nights on fon g5 would be
actually good yeah this is maybe what I
should try like Knight f3 here King age
to 91 92 nite f4 there's actually the
engine line I didn't I just only now see
this this is actually my own idea now it
gives King f1 Bishop e7 this my dev for
this is better my night isn't doing that
all that much on d 2 and this avoids all
counterplay based on g5 yeah even though
the engine doesn't really feel like this
is any of them nice one naba this is
already dangerous 95 I mean now know my
position feels very uncoordinated even
though the computer thinks it's okay
with my god okay yeah there are probably
multiple ways for him to win a mini he
played something that ultimately did win
so class it's impossible clap I mean
it's maybe maybe can win quick or
anything but you did it all right you
just play it too slowly like I usually
do yeah yeah plateless very badly
technically from after I mean this is
this opening result is fantastic at what
why just has this attack oh the engine
actually thinks but I can take this
piece I didn't think so remarkable f5 I
thought after f5 I just take here isn't
that good okay no it isn't a queen gets
threat ah ok yeah the computer laughs
like I mean it always loves black in the
Kings Indian attack because it sometimes
doesn't see the mates coming but maybe
this is really not that great a possum
Queen e8 sometimes you can you can play
this this kind of thing and totally play
on the edge of play for the Aged phone
and this is also tricky for with the
computer because it sometimes does not
see the mate on the edge for coming
guess Luke a six and now f3 you with an
advantage for King f2 routledge one and
probably if you give it more depth that
will get higher I don't know I don't
know yeah I'm also takes a great game
thanks for watching